all over the world
clash
in Nature's Savage Battle of survival on
the open Plains
in the jungle underworld
and beneath desert skies
all are locked in deadly conflict
animals fight tooth and Claw to win food
territory and rights to the bloodline
from the heart of Africa to the
Himalayas there are no rules
this is Animal Fight Night
in the forests of India
the real king of the jungle
attacks a sloth bear mom
but she is no easy meal
[Music]
the sloth bear has an identity crisis
first thought to be a sloth it acts more
like an anteater
its three-inch claws crack rock hard
Earth
to find termites
a gap in its front teeth helps suck them
up
and it's sloth-like Shaggy coat Shields
against insect bites
cubs live with mom for almost three
years
and she's fiercely protective
[Music]
but the forest hides deadlier foes than
other bears
fear
Are Not Alone
a Bengal tiger
500 pounds of Ambush assassin
can strike at 35 miles an hour
break a neck with a sudden bite
a hunt in 100 degrees is thirsty work
for this Prime mail
but someone else wants a drink
a three-year-old sloth bear cub
[Music]
the Tiger
cat food
but it won't come cheap
mom throws herself In Harm's Way
[Music]
oh
the Predators fangs search for her neck
but Mom squirms free
[Music]
at less than half his weight
she has to go big
when threatened sloth bears charge and
Stand Tall to intimidate
it's a bluff
and it works
for now
mom must make sure he doesn't sneak back
he risks her own life to protect her cub
but pushes the cat too far
his lightning reactions are hardwired
in a tiger's nervous system the neurons
are supersized
with massive branches so they send
signals to the muscles extremely fast
which gives the cat incredible reaction
speeds
he has a bone-crunching one thousand
pound bite but those three-inch canines
are sensitive
a network of pressure sensing nerves
means he can precisely locate the kill
spot at the spinal cord just by feeling
with his fangs
if his teeth find their target
is dead
foreign
[Music]
the tiger tires
mom seizes her moment
she has inch and a half killer fangs
and her Rock cracking claws can be
lethal
he's injured
but drives the Predator back
the Ambush assassin again calls her
Bluff
a tiger can swipe with ten times the
force of a heavyweight boxer
ain't worth the fight
Nature's battles aren't always won by
size
risks
you're prepared to take
ing together can improve your odds
alone
you could be a dead dog walking
[Music]
okay
winter in Yellowstone
can hit -60
and no one wants to be left out in the
cold
in a coyote pack only the alphas hold
reading rights
but this young rebel wants to mate
the alpha male sees him
he'll banish rule Breakers from the clan
it's the coyote code
around
here
[Music]
the outcast must leave the territory
and go solo
on its own
a coyote's survival rate almost halves
but he strikes gold
a deer caucus
except it's under guard
from North America's biggest raptor
the golden eagle is a 200 mile an hour
assassin her beat is keratin covered
bone
hooked to rip flesh
she'll take on prey up to six times her
size
so a lone coyote is in trouble
launches a surprise attack
[Music]
three times her weight
but she has a killer advantage
seven foot wingspan Powers razor-tipped
Flying Kicks
[Music]
powerful muscles in an eagle's legs can
exert a force of up to 400 pounds
three times stronger than a human hand
the grip is near Unbreakable
pigmented tendons in the toes lock the
talons in place
like a lethal zip tie
the coyote takes the risk
just one scrap of meat could be
life-saving
but she blocks him at every turn
the coyote can't win against the ratchet
clawed guard
[Music]
the eagle keeps its prize
the outcast needs a meal soon
or he too could become bird food
the Himalayas
home of the mythical Yeti
and the hunting grounds of a real ghost
thank you
the snow leopard
is the apex predator of a territory that
rises nearly twenty thousand feet
against Rock her camouflage makes her
all but disappear
she's after ibex
but makes a mistake
Exposed on Snowy ground
the Ibex spotter
her cover's blown
in this harsh environment only one in
five of a snow leopard's hunts ends with
a Kill
she'll survive off a carcass for up to
four days
and only hunt less than once a week
tactic that conserves energy but means
every kill is critical
the ghost finds another Target
foreign
he's a 100 pound prize
but she has her own deadly defense
strategy
specialized split hooves help barrels
Scale near vertical Cliffs
so they graze close to Cliff edges to
give them a fast Escape Route
and lure enemies into Danger
this time the leopard learns
stocks low against the rocks
Ben pounces
and makes a deadly error
thank you
at a 40 mile an hour Sprint the
leopard's own momentum takes them both
over the edge of a 400 foot drum
they stay locked in Mortal Kombat
the leopard hits powder at over 40 miles
an hour
Beryl tries her downhill getaway
strategy
but the leopard digs in
her prey may be a mountain escape artist
but she is a free fall specialist
the midsection of a cat's spine has
three more vertebrae than a human's with
highly elastic discs
this helps them twist their body in
midair to adopt Free Fall position
an ability known as the aerial writing
reflex
by flattening out they can increase
their surface area and their drag
and their long muscular legs can absorb
more energy on impact
so the barrel may be a goner
but the ghost lives on
with a prize that will keep her going
for another week
[Music]
when your gang is over a thousand strong
making decisions Ain't Easy
but Kate Buffalo have it covered
through peace or War
when it's time to travel females favor
the Democratic approach and vote
there's no Ballot Box on the Serengeti
so they stand up each facing the
direction they want to move in
majority rules
problem
amicably solved
males on the other hand can be less
diplomatic
[Music]
a water hole is everyone's favorite
place to chill
[Music]
but a band of Bachelor Buffalo are about
to change the vibe
fresh from his mud bath Dirty Harry
thinks he's the boss
while Mr Clean over here
has other ideas
at stake mating rights in a herd
Mr Clean and Dirty Harry stride parallel
check out what each other's packing
they're well matched 50 50.
but Mr Clean wants to improve his odds
with a sneak attack
he meets almost a ton of resistance
[Music]
thank you
Dirty Harry readies for a Face-Off
but Mr Clean doesn't feel lucky
and backs away
[Music]
too late
Harry's pumped for a fight
a bull can drive forwards with the force
of a pickup truck
caught sideways Mr Clean can't push back
[Music]
thank you
another bull takes a ringside seat
it distracts Dirty Harry
while Mr Clean brings out his magnums
a four inch thick battering ram with
three foot long hooks sharp enough to
gore the throat
Harry finds traction
to unleash his trademark move
[Music]
he drives his opponent a sideways
off balance and out of contention
head high chin out
Dirty Harry shows he's boss
and when the next herd moves through
Harry gets the girls
survival is a balance between risk
and reward
a leopard weighs up her odds
Impala
100 pounds of protein-rich meat
but faster than her by 10 miles an hour
it goes wrong
it's energy wasted
so it's an expensive Gamble
in her favor night vision
six times more effective than a human's
and her strategy
stealth gets her close
[Music]
the gamble pays big
expert climbers leopards take their
winnings high up in trees
where they can't be reached by
scavengers
unless that scavenger
is another leopard
[Music]
this Prowler prefers to let someone else
do all the work
oh
and then steal the prize
if she can
the thief scores a morsel
but what she wants
is a share of the main course
but so do other deadlier thieves
it's now a fight
on three fronts
foreign
the leopards are not alone
spotted hyena
they're large numbers and bone-crushing
bite usually stack the odds in their
favor
even against leopards
they're also clever opportunists
they sense trouble Brewing
and a chance for a low energy low risk
reward
in an animal's brain a large frontal
cortex is believed to aid social
communication and problem solving
the spotted hyenas is highly developed
on par with some of our close primate
cousins
so they're not just here to watch
they've got a game plan
they know a leopard fight over prey
could mean falling scraps of meat
above them a theme sounds a warning
but it falls on deaf ears
her only course now is war
the hunter defends
[Music]
with both sets of retractable claws
thief's off balance
the hyena wait
another swipe
and the thief's down
but the hyena don't want her
the hunter took her paws off the prize
and lost it
the hyena plan pays off
minimum risk
maximum reward
on the African Battleground everyone
sees the big guns
but the most effective weapon
can be a concealed carry
red build quilia one of the most
destructive birds in the world
[Music]
1.5 billion Rome sub-Saharan Africa
and devour 16 000 tons of vegetation
every day
[Music]
but while Mom and Dad gather food
day old chicks are defenseless
Far Below
a battalion of armored ground crickets
harmless Hoppers they ain't
they're also hungry
yeah
The Crickets are heavy duty assassins
a powerful bite
turns prey into mincemeat
while a tough exoskeleton and thorax
spikes Shield them from predators
and they have an incredible secret
weapon
Veil devour almost anything
even
baby birds
hearing organs in the cricket's knees
sense the chick's movements
[Music]
and lead them
to lunch
not so fast
please
mom's beak can Pierce insect flesh
but he's armor plated
and Deals his secret Ace
chemical warfare
the ground Cricket has a gruesome
defense strategy
instead it's heart pumps its blood
freely around the body
so when a special seam in its leg joint
opens
it shoots a high pressure jet of acrid
blood at any Target within two and a
half inches
[Music]
this deters predators and can even
temporarily blind them
eyes full of blood
mom can't see
but she's not done
the cricket's tough exoskeleton saves
him
but the smell of his chemical weapon
attracts more hungry mouths
his own Army turns on him
these crickets are cannibals
facing death prey must make a
split-second decision between flight
fight or
fright
on the Serengeti
a lioness Strays from her Pride
and spies prey an olive baboon
[Music]
but even against a predator over five
times his size
this Braveheart won't go down without a
fight
an olive baboon is no pushover
from just six years of age a male is
battle ready
he roams from Troop to troop to avoid
inbreeding but faces Fierce competition
for females at every stop
he uses aggressive Scare Tactics to
drive off rivals
the roar grunt
the threat yawn
which Bears fangs that can grow even
longer than a lion's
Ace
a comic azi charge
baboons also use their scare tactics to
frighten off predators
all right
but a lioness loves a baboon Buffet
he usually hunts as part of a team
and uses Ambush tactics
to take down prey up to a ton
the Lioness tries a sneak attack
Braveheart pushes back
foreign predator
50 pounds of monkey meat is a square
meal
but no dish
is worth a face full of fang
his Scare Tactics seemed to work
he could quit while he's ahead
and run
but he
he just keeps on pushing
he tries a threat yawn
it's time
threats won't help him
the Lioness is head of an ambush Squad
they take both flanks
to Corner their prey
the Braveheart baboon
pushed too far
even for scavengers
a free lunch
is too good to be true
in the Namib Desert a stinks in the air
again carcass
10 pounds of protein Rich meat still
cling to its bones
it sends a tempting scent for miles
a black back Jackal and her daughter
search for food
[Music]
her nose is thousands of times more
sensitive than a human's
picks up Rotting Flesh from over a mile
away
jackals have a special structure in
their nose that humans lack
it's a maze of channels that helps it
detect chemicals that we can't even
sense
and analyze them in extraordinary detail
[Music]
each nostril can take in independent
sense samples
which helps the jackals zero in
on the source of the smell
even the stench of rotting meat
doesn't mask
a new scent
[Music]
tail down
ears flick
mom's uneasy
another jackal
he's hungry
today lunch will come at a price
a 4 000 calorie prize is just enough to
keep mom and daughter going for another
two days
but the newcomer wants a share of their
meal
this could go either way
resident jackals sometimes allow
newcomers a seat at their table
they're related
if not
the Intruder can be sent home with a
Savage souvenir
mom's nose will tell her if the stranger
is family
or not
a raised paw is a peace offering
but mom won't share
the Intruder urinates
a sign she's stressed
jackals Target the throat to kill
mom takes the ear
it's a canine attack strategy that says
back off
the Intruder tries to loosen mom's grip
and aim for her jugular
[Music]
mom drives the message home
and it sticks
mom and daughter reap their reward
the Intruder goes hungry but gets away
intact
scraps over meat may get bloody but when
your whole turf's at stake
it's War
in the meerkat Kingdom the queen Reigns
Supreme
Fierce rulers they're more aggressive
than the males
with three times the testosterone
Queen
working mom
she feeds her Young
and commands a 30 strong Army
Soul breeder the size of her Army is a
sign of her success
she's pregnant and won't fight
so her troops will defend with 11
different alarm calls that help identify
the enemy and Threat Level
they're Code Red
is a rival Clan
a marauding mob wants to expand its
territory
Queen out of action
be the perfect time to strike
the Home Guard spots them
they'll defend Queen and country with
their lives
they line up
Tails like banners
an intimidation tactic to avoid a costly
War
cats may look cute
but they'll fight to the death
known to kill a rival Clans pups
the Marauders attack
their canines Target the home guard's
throats
thank you
Advantage Marauders
without their Fierce Queen the Home
Guard could lose everything
its first blood to the Marauders
[Music]
but the queen has greater numbers
they overturn the enemy
one of her soldiers aims a parting shot
the chewed tail proves the final blow
[Music]
the Marauders fall back
it's a white flag
strength in numbers
the queen secures her kingdom
in the jungle underworld
there's a biological weapon
so devastating that some believe it
defies evolution
a lumbering giant looks for lunch
but finds other Hunters
foraging ants
in attack mode
The Beatles 60 times their size
but they call in backup
from a near indestructible Army
ants have survived for about 140 million
years
that wiped out the dinosaurs
Harden chitin exoskeleton protects them
but the real secret to their success
is their organization
they live in million strong colonies
but can behave
like a single organism
some even unite and form rafts to
survive floods
it makes for an army of hyper-efficient
killers
foragers divide into specialized units
the first unit finds large prey
it releases chemical trails for backup
to follow
foragers send their message the beetle
is on borrowed time
but it has its own message
total annihilation
it's a bombardier beetle
one of a family of insects with 200
degree toxic chemicals in their Arsenal
some people believe this weapon is too
complex to have evolved naturally
the spray is so hot it should cook them
alive from the inside out
but evolution has an answer to
everything
inside the beetle to types of gland
produce two different chemicals
they're harmless until released together
into a reinforced chamber
as the chemicals combine to form a toxic
cocktail the reaction Heats it to
Boiling Point
pressure caused by the heat blast the
spray out in 500 pulses per second
and each pulse allows the chamber to
cool so the beetle doesn't burn up
it can even rotate its Cannon 270
degrees for precision Firepower
spray Burns and ants tough chitin
exoskeleton
choose doomsday survivors
can handle a bombardier's biological
warfare
[Music]